[APPLAUSE]
R. RIGHT AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ADDRESS ON THE BORDER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SENT OUT THESE
TWO CARNIVAL CUTOUTS AS A
REBUTTAL.
ALL THAT IS MISSING WAS A
BEANBAG FOR THEIR PIE HOLES.
ARE WE SURE SURE THIS WASN'T A
SUBTLE PROPOSAL FOR THE NEW
SEASON OF THE WALKING DEAD
BROUGHT TO YOU BY THE MAKERS OF
FORMALDEHYDE.
IT'S ORDER LIST TASTELESS TO
KEEP SURE GOVERNMENT FOR
DECADES.
LOOK AT THEM.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY
LOOK.
THAT'S TOO EASY.
IT'S JUST HOW THEY ARE LIKE A
COUPLE OF GRADERS AT CIGAR
WORLD.
OLD PEOPLE GET THAT.
YOU WANT A WALL?
BAFTA WALL.
THEY ARE SO RIGID THEY MAKE MIKE
PENCE LOOK LIKE THIS GUY.
♪♪
GREG: IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT
WERE THEY THINKING?
>> ON THE FIRST DAY OF THIS
CONGRESS HOUSE DEMOCRATS PASSED
SENATE LEGISLATION.
>> WHERE AM I?
WERE DRY LOOK, STRAIGHT AHEAD?
SHOULD I HAVE ONE MIGHT LAST AS?
THEY TICKLE MY NOSE.
WHY DOES SHE GET TO SPEAK FIRST?
SHE ALWAYS DOES.
I HATE HER.
I'M A SENATOR SO I GET TO STAND
ON A LITTLE WOODEN BOX.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY SQUIRRELS
IT TOOK TO MAKE THIS WE HAVE?
I LOVE SQUIRRELS.
THEY HAVE BIG FLUFFY TAILS.
THEY COVER MY BALD SPOT.
GREG: IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
PROOF OF HOW SCREWED UP
GOVERNMENT IS LOOK NO FURTHER.
TRUMP'S ADDRESS WAS NOT EARTH
SHATTERING.
HE WITHIN THE LINES AND STUCK TO
THE FACTS.
HE REVIEWED THE SAME POINTS THAT
DEMOCRATS STATED BEFORE.
DIDN'T MATTER THE MEDIA WAS
GIDDY WITH FACT-CHECKING.
FACT CHECKERS IT EASIER WITH YOU
TODAY.
WE WILL BE FACT-CHECKING
RELENTLESSLY.
>> A TESTABLE CHECK THE FACT
CHECKERS LATER ON TONIGHT.
GREG: THEY ARE SO EXCITED.
THEY ARE LIKE KEVIN SPACEY AT A
HIGH SCHOOL WRESTLING MATCH.
BUT WHEN THE TIME CAME THERE
WASN'T MUCH TO FACT CHECK.
THE CRIME STATS WERE LEGITIMATE.
THE ADDICT DOTES TRUMP LISTED
SADLY WERE ALL REAL WHICH IS WHY
THEY HAD TO REDEFINE
FACT-CHECKING AT DISGRUNTLED
COMMENTARY.
SERIOUSLY I WONDER WHAT THEY
WERE THINKING.
>> WE ADDRESS YOU TONIGHT FOR
ONE REASON ONLY.
>> I COULD REALLY GO FOR A
HOAGIE WITH CHEESE ONIONS LET US
PICKLES MUSTARD.
>> PASTRAMI, SALAMI, TOMATOES,
MORE CHEESE.
>> WE DON'T GOVERN BY TEMPER
TANTRUM.
>> WHY DOES CHEESE HAVE PULLS?
THAT'S A RIPOFF.
OH GOD, BUT WHAT IS THAT SMELL?
OH CHUCK NOT AGAIN.
SEE IT DOCTOR PLEASE.
GREG: OF COURSE THE MEDIA MADE
FOOLS OF THEMSELVES PRETENDING
THERE IS NO CRISIS WHEN THE WEEK
BEFORE THEY WERE CALLING IT A
CRISIS THEMSELVES.
REMEMBER THE CARAVAN?
WASN'T THAT A CRISIS?
NOT ANYMORE.
>> A BIG SCAM OF THE WHOLE
ADDRESS WAS THAT THERE WAS A
CRISIS.
THERE IS NOT A CRISIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH WAS A
LITANY OF SCARE STORIES ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS BEING TERRIBLE
CRIMINALS.
>> THIS IS A CRISIS THAT HE
WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
>> THAT ADDRESS SHOULD HAVE COME
WITH A SURGEON GENERAL'S WARNING
, IT'S HAZARDOUS TO THE
TRUTH.
GREG: YOU KNOW HE HAD A PRACTICE
THAT LINE IN FRONT OF A BATHROOM
MIRROR.
IF JIMMY DOESN'T MAKE TRUMP'S
POINT FOR HIM.
>> HERE ARE SOME OF THE STEEL
SLATS THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT HERE.
AS WE ARE WALKING ALONG WE ARE
NOT SEEING ANY IMMINENT DANGER.
THERE ARE NO MIGRANTS TRYING TO
WEAR START DEFENSE IN THE
MCALLEN TEXAS AREA.
NO SIGN OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT IT'S PRETTY
TRANQUIL DOWN HERE.
GREG: OKAY SO HERE I AM IN FRONT
OF A WALL AND THERE ARE NO
ILLEGAL'S CROSSING IT.
[APPLAUSE]
SOME PEOPLE --
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT CALL THAT
CAUSE AND EFFECT BUT NOT JIM.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
EACH OTHER.
HERE I AM HOLDING AN UMBRELLA IN
THE RAIN AND MY GOD I AM DRY.
CLEARLY THERE IS NO RAIN.
NOW WHEN I PUT ON THESE
SUNGLASSES SUDDENLY THE SUN'S
GLARE IS GONE.
OBVIOUSLY THE SUN HAS GONE
MISSING.
BUT I WONDER IF TRUMP
APPRECIATED THE SALES PITCH.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: I DON'T CARE, I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU THINK OF TRUMP YOU
COULD PUT THEM ON RUSHMORE FOR
THAT ALONE.
AS FOR POOR GYM JIM THAT WASN'T
THE WORST PART OF THIS WEEK.
>> WILL THE PRESIDENT TELL THE
TRUTH?
>> THE WHOLE TRUTH AND NOTHING
BUT THE TRUTH, SO HELP YOU GOD?
MAKE SURE THAT GOES VIRAL.
BY THE WAY I'M ONE OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE AROUND HERE THIS TIME OF
DAY.
LET ME GET BACK TO YOUR CASE
BECAUSE YOU ARE SUCH A.
THAT MAY BE RESPECTFUL TO THE
MEDIA.
I EXPLAINED THAT WAS ALTERNATIVE
FACTS AND DON'T YOU PUT IT BACK
IN MY FACE.
GREG: I HAVE A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> AND NOW A PUBLIC SERVICE
GREG: IF YOU HAPPEN TO COME
ACROSS TO PRINT SIZED ORBS
ROLLING ACROSS PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE PLEASE PUT THEM ON ICE
AND PROPERLY RETURN THEM TO JIM
ACOSTA.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: THE CRISIS IS NOW IN
CIRCUS.
THE MEDIA MAKES EVERYTHING WORSE
INCLUDING EVEN POLITICS WHICH IS
LARDED THE WORST THING EVER.
POLITICS IS THE INVISIBLE GAS
REMOVING NUANCE AND COMPROMISES
REPLACING BOTH WITH WHAT I CALL
THE PRESIDENT OF TWO IDEAS.
EACH SIDE MUST PICK THEIR SALAD
NEVER LEAVE SO EVEN IF CHUCK
AGREED WITH TRUMP IT DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER HERE'S THE STATUS
ELEMENT MEDIA MAKES IT WORK
WORSE BY TURNING PRISON INTO A
BUSINESS MODEL.
THERE'S NO WAY IN D.C. OR "NEW
YORK TIMES" CAN MAKE MONEY IF
CHUCK AND NANCY AGREE WITH
TRUMP.
COMPROMISE DOESN'T SELL
ADVERTISING.
MEANWHILE THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE
BY TWO YEARS OF PEACE AND
PROSPERITY.
THE ONLY WAY WE HAVE ENDURED
THIS MALFEASANCE IS THAT ALL THE
BIG STUFF IS TAKEN CARE OF JOBS,
TERROR ECONOMY.
BECAUSE TRUMP IS GONE DOWN THIS
LIST AND PICKED OFF OF THE BIG
THINGS VICTIMS CAN AFFORD TO
HOLD WORKERS HOSTAGE AND
ATTENDING WALLS ARE A MORAL
PHENOMENON IN WHICH TRUMP HAS
INVENTED.
MAKES YOU WANT TO TURN OFF THE
NEWS AND GOD FORBID TALK TO YOUR
FAMILY.
MOST OF ALL IT MAKES YOU SEE
THINGS AS THEY REALLY ARE OR
RATHER WHO THEY REALLY ARE AND
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY THINKING.
>> WHERE AM I?
AM I STILL HEAR?
I SHOULD BE HOME FOR IN-APP "THE
GREG GUTFELD SHOW" WAS ON SURE
HE CAN BE RUDE BUT I FIND THEM
TO BE SPOT ON IN HIS ANALYSIS.
MAYBE SHE CAN GET A JOB WRITING
FOR GREG GUTFELD.
WHAT IS THAT SMELL?